hi I'm Andrew Kreisberg I'm co-creator
and executive producer of the flash and
I'm Greg Berlanti we're really excited
it's going to have some of the biggest
special effects you never then we have
sort of a new way to introduce all sorts
of incredible villains so we could get
more pumped that team flash is trying to
stop savitar these are the final
moments I remember Andrew Kreisberg
coming to me and telling me how it would
all kind of go down in the end I
remember saying to him that is so cool
young girls and young boys everywhere
are going to be thrilled with her being
the one to kind of take that final shot
at savitar all these months you were trying
to save me from him look at that I thank
you it's empowering it's empowering that
iris has kind of been this damsel all
season and kind of struggled with Savitar looming over her she's the one that
has the final say and his last breath
you ready for team flash to take down
the bad guys again the best episode
we've done this year is the one I
directed I wasn't on came the flash once
in future flash in that there was this
there's this moment where we put our
hands together and we do remember okay
anybody and team flash flash watching
how excited tom felton the person got to
play Julian Albert the character and how
excited he was to be a member of Team
flash I was one of the salient
highlights of season three for me
watching this guy be excited about
something we were doing together as a
group
just, wait no!
after my first episode my managers like
so how wasn't like him
looks like amazing you know it was that
was just like a schoolgirl I was just
beaming because it the cast is amazing
the crews amazing everyone's so sweet
and actually like everyone's so grateful
for the opportunity to be telling this
story and to be here working with one
another very good book it works I'm a
fan I was like episode 8 or 9 when I
first went into the cortex and everyone
was like oh my god the energy is amazing
and they were so welcoming to me and I
was a little nervous but they just with
open arms welcomed me in and that was really nice
surprise surprise everybody
little tags for the beginning of season
for the end of season 3 I like the
connective tissue they always provide so
I'm going to explain what's going on
behind the scenes there is a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video that's going to
be going on all summer but this week
there's a special Wonder Woman ticket
giveaway going on I'll name a new winner
for that at the end of this video so you
guys want to know what's going on with
season four first I'll talk about the
season 3 post mortem stuff the behind
the scenes is really cool as they start
to set up for season 4 but there's a
really highly structured way that they
produce this show so right now they're
finishing their break like it's Memorial
Day in the United States so it's a
national holiday so most people are on
vacation but what's happening is is
after that's over the next couple of
days
the writers come back in they start
breaking the season 4 story and then
they have the idea like they break the
idea of savat are before season 3 hey
wouldn't it be cool if flashpoint led to
the idea of a time remnant version of
beary deciding that his existence was
more valid than berries and decided that
the ultimate way to get rid of his pain
would be to become a god and what would
that do to the characters so they break
ideas like that
so whatever the big theme of season 4 is
going to be however season 3 is going to
change the characters that's what
they'll decide in the next couple of
weeks
then they'll sit down and start writing
the scripts then they meet with the
actors they talk about their character
arcs so they break out the big story
first then they break out character arcs
like what's going to happen to bury this
season what's going to be happening to
iris what's going to happen to Tom
Cavanagh
as we killed HR are we going to bring
back Harrison wells from earth-2 for the
entire season what's going to be
happening to Julian is he going to stick
around for the entire season just for
Kaitlyn in Kaitlyn is probably the
biggest change because this will be the
first season that we won't have somebody
that's permanently on Team flash at the
end of the season in the beginning of
the season
she said I'm gonna go off and figure my
stuff out she'll be back
oh yeah for sure she will definitely be
back but I totally love all of the time
jump theories that you guys are throwing
at me so if you don't watch The Walking
Dead they've been talking about how
there's going to be a jump in time
between this season in the next season
in wouldn't it be crazy if the flash did
something like that like they picked up
at the beginning of season four in it's
five years later five years that Berry
has been gone and stuck in the Speed
Force instead of just being the normal
three months that usually passes between
seasons so while that is completely
intriguing there's no evidence to
support that they're actually going to
do that so do think about that though
because in the comics what happened
after Barry died is that Wally West was
the flash for many many years almost
20-plus years before they brought Barry
Allen back mid-80s crisis deaths to
early 2000s geoff johns rebirth and the
official return of Barry Allen so the
only reason that I don't think they're
going to go that hardcore is just the
way they treated flashpoint on the TV
show and they accomplished it with one
Episode I think there was a little bit
of disappointment with that so that's
when they addressed stuff like that when
they're breaking the new season hey we
did this big flashpoint arc but people
were kind of upset that we builded his
flashpoint but it only lasted for a
single episode so if we're going to do a
big comic book thing like the Speed
Force storm Barry Allen being stuck in
that Speed Force prison we better find a
more rewarding way to pay that off
what's happened to Barry while he's been
in there they said that it's health will
he come back a changed man that's
actually the more important thing and
then what will happen is is a couple
weeks before Comic Con sometime in June
they actually start shooting that first
episode if you remember way back to the
beginning of season three we actually
started seeing pictures of them on set
we started seeing Instagram posts we saw
a lot of the photographer's that camp
the set posting pictures of the rival
everyone's like oh my god is this the
new big bad and there's Wally West in
the flash
costume what's going on he was crazy
even the producers came out and they're
like no no no this is the rival Savitt
ours the big villain won't make his
appearance for a while so just expect
the exact same thing to happen this
summer we'll get a tease for people
walking around on set we'll finally see
Grant Gustin on set what I'm expecting
is is that just because it's such a big
thing that bear is stuck in the
speedforce is that when they pick up an
episode one wall-e will have been the
flash for at least the last couple of
months and it'll be like flashpoint
picking up where he and I risk work as a
team they have everybody at STAR Labs
Caitlin is still off on her own and then
things start to happen to lay
circumstances that provide for Barry's
return as well as all the craziness of
season 3 because the flashpoint twist
was what set-offs avatar set off the
rival when they got to episode 2 so just
don't be surprised if it's episode 2
before Barry is back in action
normally a regardless of how he shows up
in episode 1 I'm expecting some rebirth
twists where he's sort of like a force
ghost for Wally and other speedsters I
need a tether please help me get back
and then he doesn't actually physically
appear till like the very end of the
episode or the beginning of episode 2
but you'll see Grant Gustin stuff
happening in the first episode there
will be almost zero episodes of the
flash in its entire run where you never
see or hear Barry Allen but I have got a
surprising number of questions this week
about whether or not Grant Gustin is
leaving the show no that's not how the
CW shows work he's a series regular he
signed a contract for seven seasons just
like Stephen Amell did so whatever might
come after that who knows but until then
he is going to be around for the long
haul the really cool post-mortem on the
season 3 stuff is that you start to see
the actors participating more in the
actual production of the show like if
you go back and you watch season 1 iris
stuff it feels so different from Candice
Patton now she's actually becoming a
little more involved in what her
character is doing Tom Cavanagh is
actually directing episodes now which i
think is really cool when you have a
situation like that where someone's
friend is directing them like he's
really close with the rest of the cast
in addition to being an amazing actor
himself and a really good director
you just get much better performances
out of everyone so expect him to direct
a couple more episode
during season four and then obviously
there's all the big teaser about the big
action set-pieces
the super animal Suicide Squad episode
that they'll probably be doing sometime
I wouldn't be surprised if that was like
their big two-part guerilla city style
episode like episode 13 and 14
each season tends to be a big two-part
episode like that that would probably be
the place to put that but they tend to
not sleep on their biggest stuff so they
have some big Suicide Squad stuff plan
will probably at least hear about that
before then but I'm expecting season 4
to largely be rogue based most of the
villains coming from Earth one but we
still have earth 19 because gipsy is
still around there'll be more people
from there we'll still have earth to
people that will pop up so we're getting
to the point on the show where they just
have more pools to pick from in terms of
characters so there was a character that
got killed off like a char from earth 19
you still have plenty more in the
multiverse to pick from if you want to
bring someone new on but there's a whole
bunch more stuff coming this week I know
a lot of you have asked me to do a video
for the Supergirl finale what I'll
probably do next is answer a couple more
big questions about flash twists like
why Wally still has powers things like
that that will post tomorrow but I also
wanted to do a finale ranking just
ranking the flash finale against arrow
Supergirl legends of tomorrow because I
know a lot of you had opinions about
that congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner shark P John 7 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details my non-spoilery Wonder Woman
review will be up in a couple hours you
can click here for that I'll update the
link when ever I post that and you can
click here for more flash season 4 thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight!